[Music]
hello there guys now this is actually a
pretty exciting video because we have um
a release date for the batman trailer 2
and early screening reactions to the
film which is sounding pretty incredible
so you know what let's just get straight
into the video so it's been confirmed
that the next trailer for the batman
will debut at the dc fandom which is on
october 16th it's not known what's going
to be shown in the trailer but if it's
anything like the first trailer i'm
personally going to be pretty stoked
because you know i love the tone of the
movie and how it looks so so i'm excited
to get a um extended look at the film
anyway on to the early reactions to the
film now this is really exciting because
it sounds like people are really loving
what they're seeing here and you know
the tone is something different that we
haven't seen in a batman before it's
more of a horror film and quite graphic
and dark which personally you know i'm
all for so you know this ticks all over
the boxes for me um anyways let's get to
the reactions so it reads here i know
someone who has seen the batman friend
of mine and a really good person here's
what they told me the batman movie is a
horror movie very graphic very dark very
scary paul dano is crazy so scary i
loved every second the cut they saw of
the batman is three hours long now this
is exciting because i'm all for longer
films you know gives more time to
develop characters more time for world
building more time for just developed a
movie overall which i think is a great
thing if it's done right um but you know
i should say that this is probably like
an assembly cut or like the first draft
of the movie so it's most likely that
we'll cut the movie down to you know two
hours or 30 minutes or something like
that um or i could be wrong and it could
be a three hour long movie which i think
would be pretty cool personally but yeah
just take that river grain of salt as a
stew editor in the film as we saw mad
reeves posts picture on twitter today
that they're still an editing floor so
now apparently they have a million
things to say about catwoman she's my
favorite definitely my favorite catwoman
now there seems to be a trend of all the
actors doing a really good job in this
film so i hope they've you know cast a
movie really well i know people a bit
unsure about robert patterson being cast
as the batman but from the early
opinions apparently he's killed it as
the role and you know he's done a really
good job um it reads here that
apparently his voice was perfect which
you can have a glimpse of in the first
trailer and i'm sure we'll hear more of
in the second trailer apparently his
batman bill it just slayed apparently
it's slayed and it's you know really
epic we can again we have a small
glimpse of it in the trailer it looks
like it's a bit more grounded um you
know i love you know the blue exhaust
flame at the back of it i think that
looks sick now this is the most exciting
part for me because apparently there's a
scene at the end that literally had
everyone screaming everyone gasped like
it was a big no way moment for everyone
so apparently there's a plot twist of
some kind at the end of the movie um
honestly i got no clue what this could
be and honestly i don't want to know
what it is you know i just want to be
surprised when i watch the movie you
know if it's such a big scene or a big
plot twist that's making people you know
scream and gasping you know i wouldn't
experience that we've you know not known
what it is so i'm really curious to see
what that's about and then he was asked
if the batman sets up for a sequel and
they said yes definitely sequel i
generally feel like they're going to
start a whole collection of robert
patterson movies and circle through
different villains maybe now that's
pretty exciting because this would be a
big comeback for batman we haven't had a
solo batman movie for like 10 years so
you know i would love to see him back on
the big screen with new movies and stuff
like that so i think that'd be really
exciting i hope the movie does well most
importantly i hope the movie is good but
judging by the early reactions and from
what i've seen from the first trailer i
think it's going to be pretty good
movies so
tell me what you guys think in the
comment section below are you guys
excited for this movie are you excited
for trailer 2 what do you think you'll
see from trailer 2 let me know in the
comment section below thanks for
watching guys